welcome back to las vegas now with the
intense heat and more people staying at
home car batteries are dying
it's important to make sure that yours
is in good shape when you are ready to
get out on the road
and here's how interstate batteries can
help
all right so we are talking the draining
of car batteries right
we are that's an issue especially during
the summer time
more than ever it's interestingly uh you
know and a lot of people would think
that the primary cause for maybe some of
these draws are primarily heat in las
vegas but right now during cobit 19
all things have changed and really
what most people aren't familiar with
the first thing that they're most used
to is the
heat but they're not used to what we
call key off draws
those key bras are when vehicles are
turned off
and we're driving more than ever now
they're just computers on wheels
and these cars that when they're turned
off they're still drawing power
and so what we have to do is anticipate
that you have the right battery
uh that knows how to handle that kind of
draw
otherwise you're going out to your
vehicle sometimes and
go to start it and it it doesn't start
and it's more so the technology the
advancing technologies
then it is really the heat right now
people with covet 19
with all that happening right now it's
having its effect where people are going
out after maybe not
turning on their car for weeks or maybe
even months right and it's not
just the heat it's these key off draws
with the advancing technologies
when the battery actually drains and
loses its power is this
damaging or is it
what happens after that it it can be but
more than ever
uh technology has forced the battery
industry to really
change with their advancements in
technology as well
you don't see it it's probably not going
to affect it a whole lot
but i will tell you interstate batteries
is known
for their uh extra efforts that they
make for
testing and precautions to ensure that
they are known as the most reliable and
trustworthy batteries in the industry
there we go that's a perfect segue to my
next question how do we prevent
this from happening to our batteries you
know what the easiest way to say it is
just drive your car uh as simple as that
is
and and probably the precautionary
method would just be this
that once a week maybe drive your car
for 20 minutes
if you're now seeing your job at home a
little more than it ever was in the past
make sure that you're driving your car
for at least 20 minutes
a week if not we have what we can sell
is maybe just jump packs that you can
come and
just reach out to a local distributor of
interstate batteries and we're happy to
provide that for you
awesome thank you and you know get out
on the road why not we've been stuck in
our houses go drive
that's right that's right all right
thank you so much chuck
my pleasure call interstate batteries at
702
7636 1825 las vegas now will be